- Okay, so I have to know about this.
I heard, my producers are telling me,
did you steal a sandwich from someone
at some point?
- Yeah, I sure did.
And you ended up like literally in jail?
When I was-
- I gotta know this story,
'cause that's an awesome story.
- Yeah.
I was, I think I was 18 years
old, well, I was 18 years old.
I was in my freshman year in
college and I had no money
and, like zero money.
I don't know how I even bought a book.
- That was me at 18 as well, yes.
- Right?
And so we were, we all went out one night,
and we were walking back from a party,
and there was a kind of
like a, not 7-Eleven,
but a 7-Eleven type store,
and so we walked in and I was like,
oh my God, I'm starving,
I haven't eaten all day.
And I stole a turkey sandwich.
And so I walked outside with my friends
and I'm like, ew, it has tomatoes on it.
So we started throwing
tomatoes in the street
because we were dorks and losers,
and then I'm eating it,
and we're all laughing,
and comes up a cop, stands
right in front of me.
And I just see like his badge,
and I look up to his face.
He's like, "You need to come with me."
And I'm like, "Are you joking me?"
He's like, "No."
So I get in the cop car,
I had to go to jail.
This kid bailed me out, his name was Liam.
He was the nicest guy, I didn't know him.
And he gave me the 100 bucks.
- You didn't know him
and he bailed you out?
- Yeah, because it was part of like,
you know, it was freshman year in college.
Everybody's kinda meeting everybody.
So I didn't know him that well,
like I, but he was so nice.
And so I borrowed the 100 dollars
from my brother the next
day, and I paid him back,
and then cut to, I don't
know how many years later,
I'm in Los Angeles and I'm at
a cafe and the guy comes up,
my waiter, and he goes,
"Do you remember me?"
I was like, "No."
He goes, "I'm Liam, I
bailed you out of jail."
- No way!
- I was like, wait, what?
That's so crazy.
'Cause I hadn't seen
him after he did that.
He like transferred schools
or something or left.
And isn't that crazy?
- That is crazy.
Well, what's crazier is I
have a surprise for you.
Liam, come on in the Zoom room!
No, I'm just kidding, no! (laughs)
- Could you, could you
imagine, could you imagine?
- I was just kidding, I just
wanted to see your bluff face,
and by the way, it looks like this.
Oh, (beep).
- Yeah. (laughs)
- All right.
I'm just kidding.
I was checking your poker face,
we don't have Liam.
- Yeah, no, I have none.
- I have none.
But if you brought Liam on,
that would be the best surprise ever.
I've always wondered what happened to him.